many people in the United States I don't  think fully appreciate the importance of  the post-world war two context of the  European integration process how it  started with the iron Coal and Steel  Community how it then went on to the  notion of a customs union the moving  towards a single market and then the  European and monetary union and with the  view leading towards some idea of  political unit and what we've clearly  are now at a critical point where the  Maastricht Treaty in the late 90s that  created the European monetary union  really focused more on the monetary than  the economic and so they're having to do  the ketchup